you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy Network now this is a
American history podcast and each week I
flamethrower eater lover of dogs man you
eat sandwiches Dave Anthony Wow
Regis story fire and sandwiches boy
mister his friend Gareth Reynolds who
has no idea what the topic is going to
be about that was good I thought you
were good
I was great on this somewhat yeah I will
say your list of three there if we could
keep them to that caliber I'm back in on
the bit you know those are solid
it's just when we're talking about like
guy who performs dish soaping oh i've
nap take a guy who pours dish soap into
the the special fancy dish soap holder
and called it quote is jam-packed
present sick arguments
young ladies and other people we are
brought to you by stance calm you know
these days you can get pretty much
anything on demand Gareth sure movies
foods salmon films like our podcast for
instance that's an example of something
can get on-demand I've been ordering it
well what if you could get postage on
demand yeah I'm talking about stamps
calm you Tod yep
with stamps calm you can access all the
services you can at the post office
right from your own house sure sitting
at your desk in front of your computer
you buy and print official US postage
for any letter any package using your
own computer in printer
mail carry comes picks it up dude what's
your mail carriers name mine's Garcon
Garson comes and he's French she's a
well I mean to tell you his story would
be lengthy but let's just say his change
from the countryside has not been easy
upon him we so Garson comes and just
picks up your stuff and that's it you
clink click you print you mail boom
you're done I use it for all the dollop
stuff email out and know that we have an
assistant I know if I told you that we
can't wait to meet this person
his name is Garcon he's having a hard
time with the transition he hasn't been
telling me everything during our port
breaks so uh so yeah it's super easy you
can get a scale and they send you all
the stuff it's perfect you know the
labels from them you can get the stamps
it's all good so right now I use dollop
for the special offer includes up to
fifty five dollars free postage a
digital scale and a four-week trial nice
now don't wait that's long in the no
just go to snaps calm before you do
anything else click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in dollop that stamps comm
enter dollop them
okay we're also sponsored by and members
of the Dollar Shave Club that's right we
which you jump on your ready for I'm
ready in addition before the show you're
going to shave it
so Dollar Shave club's everything you
need for shaving and just to make
yourself nice in the bathroom yeah I've
always wanted to make myself nice in the
bathroom you pervert
I use I use their razors it's fantastic
Dave just because I have a beard doesn't
mean I'm not using them wink wink wink
wink in the sink let's stop it they
deliver everything you need to look feel
and smell your best which you know you
could help you smell so yeah you got
shampoo conditioner body wash body wash
body wash toothpaste hair gel and even a
wipe that'll leave your tush feeling
nice and clean alright they got a bottom
wipe that's good for you
I don't I'm not a fan of that angle
you're working okay
well that's why they call you dirty
bottom ready Gary so it was a great way
to try a bunch of Dollar Shave club's
products for just 5 bucks you can get
their daily essentials starter set it
comes with body cleanser one wipe
Charlies since I'm talking about baby
they're amazing butt wipes I guess
that's know I'm talking about their
world-famous shave butter which also you
can put on your box and their best razor
the 6 blade executive which I'm what I
use yeah but I'm gonna have you use it
on my bottom yeah better shave your
bottom more than once executive you keep
the blades come in for a few more bucks
a month and add in shampoo toothpaste or
anything else you need for the bathroom
check it all out at dollarshaveclub.com
slash dollop that's dollarshaveclub.com
slashed dollop we are also sponsored by
something you like to sleep on my friend
Castorp services nope nope you don't do
that anymore sorry Casper you you enjoy
your Casper I'm the owner of a Casper
mattress nice to sink into that bad boy
yeah you know the truth is when I tell
people how much time I spend in bed they
look sad but they don't know that
feeling of the Casper I like just
opening up the box and watching it come
out yeah I like locking the door to the
bedroom and just getting a bag of Fritos
and just spending 36 hours in there
without leaving
that's called depression ha ha Casper uh
sorry our podcast listeners are invited
to take advantage of Casper's
competitive limited time amore all day
sale offer Casper is the place to shop
for Memorial Day mattress savings this
year they sell directly to you
eliminating added cost and saving you
money
you can be sure your purchase with
Casper's 100 night risk-free risk-free
not fee sleep on a trial and returns are
hassle-free if you're not completely
satisfied and you're gonna be trusting
Casper has three matches lines to choose
from the original Casper which is the
one that has the ghost in it the
innovative wave and extremely essential
amazing someone sold a haunted mattress
I mean he's nice but I don't want him in
my life he keeps talking about things we
have to do sir they're called Casper
mattresses I understand that but I was
very clear when I ordered it I don't
want the one with the ghost address for
the original ah it's the language you
had on the site I guess I don't know but
all right well we got to go find a
friend of his
well I guess is 75 now what the hell is
going on all right thank you feds comfy
though the breathable design of each
mattress helps you sleep cool and
regulate your body temperature
throughout the night for a limited time
visit Casper calm savings and receive
10% off your order with any mattress
purchase this off special offer expires
May 29th
2018 again that's Casper calm savings
for 10% off your order with any mattress
purchase until May 29th 2018 terms and
conditions apply
boom okay well I would like to say that
this podcast is also sponsored by Mitch
Hurwitz
who one time asked if he could just be
announced as a sponsor and I said for
sure but that leads me to a great point
Dave which is that the new season of
Arrested Development starts on Netflix
May 29th worldwide and that is a show I
worked quite some time on and people
should check it out I saw some the other
night and they're funny
yeah and the cast is hilarious and I
would watch the show anyway enough about
that also on top of that Arrested
Development May 29th oh god I mean that
was really bad timing for you we've
we've had a spill Aaron how do we handle
it we were trying we were doing space
work you know this is all I'm sure a lot
of horrible stuff has happened in this
studio so a whole thing at tea is fine
it was nice iced tea that was a good
iced tea we'll get you another one can
we get him another one that's somebody
gonna do you know what sums nobody else
who does podcasts here is like a
reasonable human being so they can just
sit in that Aaron Aaron I'm sorry does
Bill burr record here does he record his
house his house so none of these other
people are all [ __ ] all right okay
I'll be a egging its Gareth again I've
got some dates coming up you can go to
Gareth Rose calm find out all those I'll
be at the Tempe improv the June first
with Dan Cummings how dare you opening
for Dan Cummings I will be there May
31st through June 2nd then I'll be at
the stress factory in New Jersey
June 21st to 23rd laughs comedy club in
Seattle June 29th and the 30th nobody
cares and then we should also mention
okay so even a lot of people are asking
about Koh Samui and what happened
so basically Gareth is working on a show
right now and then there's a possibility
that he was gonna get another job and
then at the same time I got offered a
job but then that kept getting delayed
and delayed and delayed so basically a
gotten to this point where we both kind
of had to get a job offer at the same
time and if we didn't it [ __ ] us
because it's hard to negotiate I want
time off when you might not when one of
you might not be going yeah
it's super super complicated so I ended
up getting the offer super last minute
and no no ability to go to Thailand they
were like you're out yeah I have to take
the job because it's like a five month
job and it's a really good job so that's
basically what happened Gareth then
learned he can go to Thailand so what
we're gonna do is I'm gonna write up a
dollop we're gonna have one of the
Australian Yahoo's read it to Gareth and
and then it'll be like a Dave ant a
dollop dog which a lot of people will be
happy well we've already had some of you
on your own so it's time to I think it's
great to bring a new possible people for
me to work with on this podcast and I
like the idea that you like you're
saying you might take a step back you
might just write them for people yeah I
think that's great but yeah so I'll be
in Thailand I think I'm gonna leave I
think I'll get there a day later than
everything else starts but I'll be there
and I'll be doing all you know all the
podcasts and all that stuff so yeah so
you have hat you'll have in the funny
part
sure right not the organized part so
there's a chance I won't get there
counseling alone which has proven very
difficult anyway that's what happened so
I have a job and it's complicating
things and hopefully you hopefully can I
don't and Erin's cleaning tee up
hopefully we can keep our live dates
also so well it will keep you up to date
on that yes I think that's it yeah I'm
sorry Erin yeah I'm sorry too
and it's dropping ice cuz there was it
slapped away in my hand that wasn't
actually going towards him there's a lid
for a reason I mean I don't know whose
side you want to take in but Erin just
shrugged yeah Erin's not happy
Erin rolled his eyes and side over here
like three or four time
1873 nice the tea yes okay
it's very tuition here the town of
Clifton was founded in eastern Arizona
okay as the miners as miners said along
the banks of the of a canyon stream near
the San Francisco River and Chase Creek
so it sounds nice right yeah I'm sold
what we are being being yep cliffs
surrounded Clifton there
the river is often often flooded which
then just washed away all the houses and
businesses that's nice though
sort of like God renovating the streets
but there's copper there so they just
kept rebuilding great I mean basically
like if you look a picture of it you'd
be like why would you build why would
you build a place they're like it's just
surrounded by cliffs that happens flying
Malibu now yeah okay that's true 1,000
feet up from Clifton was the town of
Morin C okay Clifton
sorry copper was also discovered there
in 1872 and mining started the next year
by 1904 Marty was a shoot-'em-up western
Helltown and fought with tombstone for
the title of toughest town in Arizona
geez yeah okay all right I don't know
what's going on now but I don't like it
when Aaron walks around I think when he
says don't worry about it to me don't
worry about don't worry about it looked
the other way he's already like you
already spilled tea [ __ ]
so mourn see was more of a camp than a
town while Clifton had a bit of a
business district sort of centralized
situation okay saloons and brothels huge
in both towns okay so that I was because
I was like which one would have that
yeah well of the two is it a business or
all of them I'm imagining Clifton has
the the higher-end brothels and sure and
mourns he has the lower well mourn sees
where it's worth it ease mama Ichi's
which is one of the best scratches it
she's an extra scratches also next doors
bugs yeah
Oh God hey guys don't go to bugs they
ain't lyin violence was common a squad
of Arizona Rangers had to come in to
settle a Mexican smelters strike in 1903
mm-hmm okay the Mexicans were upset
their pay was being cut by 10% okay
the mostly white miners and the Mexican
smelters squared off okay because
obviously the white guys are bringing
the rocks up and stuff and they're like
well do your [ __ ] job and smelled it
or we're [ __ ]
right
we don't care if you get paid right so I
think it sounded like that but it was
not far off but before anything happened
between this two stylist IDEs a big rain
storm hit and water ripped through
Clifton destroyed a hundred thousand in
property and killing 50 people hey
remember when we was arguing Felucia hey
God doesn't like to strike yeah boy
can't believe we were arguing over town
that's not here anymore
so that kind of ended the strike the
feelings behind the strike yeah no no
then there's bigger fish to fry so the
leaders were then arrested and put in
jail okay obviously this did nothing to
help with racial tensions in the area
right so they rebuild they keep going
health and sanitation report both pens
had bad water and bad air and we're
polluted by the smell the smelters
emissions right sure the big towers
spewing out black do they know other
towns exist or they're just aware of the
other things have a lot of towns work
back okay
this led to a high rate of infertility
in both towns which led to a lot of
couples wanting children mmm this was
called baby hunger oh well it's very
it's a little close for my liking water
baby no no baby a bit still hunger
hunger for baby um
her belly's growling cuz it ain't got
something living in that womb she's baby
hungry
she's got baby hunger Mexican and
Mexican Americans made up about 60% in
Clifton and 70% in Morrissey mm-hmm but
the copper mines created and backed a
rigid hierarchy okay right why it's got
the best jobs in the best pay the whites
do yeah yeah it's like a reverse of
America very straight up very weird they
were given a lot of opportunity
interesting white also had more of a
broad definition in towns like this than
in other places in the u.s. why person
can be a dog dog could be a white person
first there were the Americans of
English descent and Scot Scottish
then a knotch down with Irish and then
Italians and Spaniards oh my god okay
so there's there's the white list
basically anyone who's not Mexican or
Chinese basic right right white right
but that's not still your level lower
tiered white yeah yeah your lower tiered
what but not here you're you're kind of
just white white lighter in New York
right and we're an Italian you're a bad
way but here you're just quite you're
cool okay okay cool that's nice yeah
that's nice yeah there were some
progress in some places yeah it's hard
to know what to fight for it was like
inner white violence like I mean they
deserve some bruises yeah I mean yeah so
the whites were not very religious but
the local Mexicans super Catholic okay
sure never colonized and destroyed okay
right and that makes you turn to Lord as
was discussed in episode 197 the orphan
trains the orphans of New York City were
a problem oh my oh no whoa baby hunger
welcome praise right now you're my mind
Palace and my number amazing ah it's
amazing to watch work I think I see it
connects it's like Stephen Hawking is
channeling through you I don't know near
the connector I've connected the dots
again on this one I think I see where
we're headed
so in New York mostly Irish kids swarmed
the streets the New York Times called
them quote ulcers of society they begged
they got the jobs they pickpocketed they
stole so the Protestant leaders in New
York agreed the best thing to do would
be to put them on trains and send them
to quote Protestant homes outside the
city okay they're just packing these
little Irish kids on trains and fired
them out into into the rest of the
country would come out as we talked
about people come out and just grab them
off the train there we go
you that would be your your child to
have sleep in the barn and work I have
issues
you're coming with us any kid not in
school could be arrested and eventually
find themselves on train whether they
had parents or not and there was no
legal obligation to tell the parents
they just grabbed a kid and put on a
train and then the parent said where's
my kid they're like yeah I guess was he
a [ __ ] yep it and he probably got put on
a train we put a bunch of the shits on
trains he lives with a different family
now Oh baby me clovers hmm I think
that's a some sort of exasperated
expression among the Irish well make
clovers I don't know what message was
sending anymore and it turns out putting
kids on a train and sending them across
the country was much cheaper than
housing them and taking care of them for
sure today we do this with something
called homeless people hmm interesting
hadn't noticed we have not we've changed
the orphan trains in a homeless buses
eventually over 100,000 children were
railroaded out of New York City and
everyone thought it was great no one on
the air ones like this is great okay
really good except the Catholics now
here we go
putting Irish Catholic kids on trains
was what they considered a cultural
genocide okay so I mean well the Irish
Catholics like why are you getting rid
of all the Catholics yeah seems really
it's weird cuz weird that's the
foundation we were sort of trying to lay
yeah we I thought this was like a place
of freedom and now there's just ninety
five of impact in a boxcar just like so
the Sisters of Charity decided to
counter it the orders first foundling
house was established in 1874 as a place
for children a foundling okay so they're
doing they're creating an orphanage
situation sure
sort of as opposed to putting them on
trains right okay right to stop the
cultural genocide sure better
the nuns allowed poor mothers to drop
off babies without question and gave
them up to three years to reclaim the
child right so that's pretty nice no
that's great that's great it's good to
know your three year window sure yeah
well and then you just got
check back in and then you can buy
another three years yeah yeah well I
still don't want him so I'll be back in
three I'll check back in and three keep
raising him they also turned to placing
kids but they follow strict guidelines
they what place them in homes okay
they all said so the ideal age is three
years old because at that point the kids
are weaned you know they're not as
reliant on the mother they're kind of
you know it's still too young that
people wouldn't try to get them to have
them as laborers on their farms or in
their house or whatever oh my god
although I bet there were some that were
like you can swing a hammer right all
right kinda families were vetted and
matched in advance there were no cattle
calls like on the orphan trains right
more of a legit sort of putting them in
places that people like a dating app yes
yes a little bit of vetting but probably
not it not and why not and why why don't
we have an app oh we've got a match
babies look at him he liked us back oh
I'm terrified because he knows I love
his profile some [ __ ] Silicon Valley
[ __ ] will be pitching this it look at
this profile you see play ain't gonna
take no for an answer
but look at those cute little rosy
cheeks I'm gonna message him let's do it
he says oh god matching babies calm
let's go send an axe emoji more most
importantly the families had to be
Catholic right and there are very
faithful Catholic Mexicans in Clifton in
Muncie okay
Clifton had a brand-new priest Father
Mandan sure he was 26 and a brand-new
clergyman's this is first first job nice
sweet spot yeah yeah it's nice he's
French we came from the French hland
nice okay he got a couple of letters
from like a real mad Crone type yeah
yeah okay he got a couple letters from
the sisters of charity in New York and
read one to his congregation so 60
parishioners applied for a a child
6060 already he picked 33 oh my god of
those 60 most were mining families it's
gonna be quite an influx of new talent
yeah
as a whole his own thing coming okay
the father earning a quote Mexican wage
made a buck 50 to 250 a day okay on
September 25th the children left from
Grand Central Station headed to their
new home in Arizona this is really weird
because it's a big batch yeah it feels
like unleashing gremlins a little it's
well I mean the cool thing is is that
they know each other like all the kids
know each other hey now
okay here's know if I again because you
know me I love to connect dots mhm
I'm the connector that's why they call
you the connector that's why I have that
show that was cancelled after eight
minutes next on CBS it was Thursday it
was canceled that for eight minutes only
fastest cancellation I remember I loved
your tagline oh well there was more to
it but that's where they cut out yeah ya
know and what it was was oh those dots
is connected that's what I would say
anyway
I don't think it's an advantage that
they all know each other there's a
shorthand there I may be not comfortable
with with this sort of type of I'm
nervous okay I don't know why you're
nervous this is a great heart with
everyone whatsoever do the heartwarming
one no no no you mean heartwarming so
sister Anna Bowen was in charge there
was also a sister and cross who are all
named Anne sister Frances Keller for
nurses and a placement agent named
George Swain hello you I'm in charge of
potting the put him in the pots and then
I sort of organised the look of the yard
with them the children were between two
and six years old okay okay yeah they
were all Irish with names like Shanley
Fitzpatrick Kane a Welsh Ryan Mac you
know the usual
yeah oh well she's a really good Irish
name I don't know just in there I bet it
is but it's still like the journey took
11 days they arrived in Clifton in the
early evening oh my god alright don't
feed him after midnight
the town did not look great the town
didn't look great okay
black smoke from the smelter Towers hung
in the air
the foster mothers were at the station
but worded spread through the town that
orphaned children were coming
did you hear little baby there's a bunch
of little babies and I think some of
them are evil but some are too it's like
picking babies off a tree if there is a
baby tree we get to pot him
we're potting them and then we'll
organize them in the garden in a whole
gaggle of white women pushed away to the
front what what and looked into the
train windows okay they were delighted
Oh baby train the girl all the girls
were in new white dresses and each
little boy was in a sailor suit
hello I'm actually evil don't you love
me mutter I've been in this for 11 days
sailor
yeah it's humming a little bit all right
say there's that look on nautical now
come on boys it's the big show is what
we were training for on that well the
Train so the children were then taken to
the priests house father man and we're
the Mexican foster mother's lined up I
mean what it's going on new boy a French
priest is hanging up handing off Irish
babies to Mexican Catholic families it's
America because it's America's New York
was like get out get them out but this
is why America is beautiful this is why
America is such a beautiful yeah it's
great race is coming it's a melting pot
it's people everybody's very accepting
and loving sure yeah no I'm sure so each
kid had a tag like a UPC sewn into their
clothes that had the name of their 1999
foster parent so and so there'd be no
mixing up of kids and kids switch shirts
or dresses well I wouldn't put it past
these little [ __ ] Irish bastards so
agents Wayne and the priests checked the
tags and then the children were put in
the arms of the new mothers it's
beautiful very good to finally have a
parent this is this is great it's a
little like Oprah giving cars away but
something happened on on the trip the
Irish Catholic the unwanted white
society in New York became super white
and wanted in Arizona
sister Anna suddenly objected to the
color difference between the mothers and
the children father man didn't did not
understand the issue kids were Catholic
the mothers were Catholic right he's
French he's like what's the [ __ ]
problem
the what has changed is that there's a
demand well but he's also French so to
him it's like why wouldn't you
Spain is fine he's she's an American
right so she's like no you don't give a
white baby to a Mexican right what are
you French but she but I was the same
they are the whole problem was both the
Catholic everything we were aiming
towards was religiously based so I don't
understand why you learn real fast sure
they're Catholics but they're Mexicans
oh my god it's like a Venn diagram yeah
so but sister Ana deferred to the priest
and figured she could take back the kids
later if she had to yes no absolutely
[Music]
oh my god the nearsightedness no you
absolutely can remove the children once
they have a comfortable foundation
reassess then remove when it's
complicated and feelings are involved
then remove that's right right yeah
thank you
then a woman who lived in the town white
woman Luiza
Gaddy okay marched in and asked for one
of the children that's it give him back
may I have one of these I don't know I
don't have anything that matches his
collar but I'm taking him I would like
one I want him then her husband showed
up he talked to the priest in French
okay and was told that no kids were
available they were all spoken for right
so he's like honey you know the app the
app hooked all these people up already
oh man it's not going well with ours I
think he's already got a family swipe
right I think he's already got a family
yeah I know
I'm not matching
a very upset white luisa left without a
child as did the other childless white
one so this is in halls parent shopping
basically yeah so the other white women
came there also had to leave worst of
all they had to sit there and watch as
Mexican women walked out with white
babies yeah the ultimate insult they
thought it wasn't right and they fumed
as one by one mexican women walked out
with a white child in their arms then
the angry white women headed back into
town the nuns had no idea anyone was
upset and they went into the sleeping
car for the night and on the train the
nuns went into the sleeping car the nuns
who brought the kids yeah right they
thought everything's fine nuns in the
shirt well arranged yeah it's a crazy
arrangement but it was arranged yes it's
a completely arranged the next morning
the the Train took the remaining 24
children in wagons and drove to mourn
see okay which is like up this crazy
hill like it's like above the town so
you got to go way up this really rough
sort of ride okay
now things went a little bit different
when they arrived at Holy Cross Church
in Morin C okay the new parents lined up
lists were checked but this time a
sister Ana rejected nine of the families
I don't know why maybe she's just said
they're too Mexican so sister Ana who
learned about the fact that some of the
Catholic families were Mexican in the
last town and now comes here and is like
oh there's a new policy
we're like American Idol now not
everybody gets on yeah right right
oh you didn't hear no you got to read
the fine print on the back of the tag on
the kids shirt little but it's there but
all the kids ended up being giving out
giving out to Mexican Catholic families
in the end
okay now the fowling group that's in
pulling all the nurses and I'm sorry the
foundling group sure and agents wing
okay that's why I have invested most of
the money is in the family group yep
then they went to the more NC hotel like
our job is done here
right they're three local men stormed it
and confronted agents Wayne
three local men one was the manager of
Detroit copper uh it should be a name of
a show
Detroit governs the company looking for
something to do ever since the connector
got cancelled Pichet I would love to
pitch it there's also the company doctor
and then another guy this was three of
them they demand to know okay now I
would like to show another guy that's
the one so the three demanded to know
how you know agents Wayne could put
white children with Mexicans okay it's a
weird one to answer an Asian swing
basically said [ __ ] off it's none of
your business
right okay back in Clifton the whites
were getting riled up never good that's
never a good sign
never good ever good thing the worst
next thing to hear is and then a
pitchfork train fell over the whites are
getting rather that happens in st. Louis
right and the whites get rather so they
were trading stories so they're they're
they're taught now they're just sitting
on talking [ __ ] about Mexicans okay the
trading stories of shiftless Mexican men
and immoral Mexican women they said they
were no better than Indians so and this
really is just like flame Fanning just
out of their just racial
young charged rather just get themselves
rile right well I heard one of them but
no I will say this I heard one of them
one of them rats Abreu friends what does
it matter
we gotta get them out of there did you
see bear yeah one of them rides on the
back of a bear and she has a sword and
she is here to cut out and eat hearts of
these little children I said you take my
Xena Zeek now the mock now with the
Mexicans
now they not know there's a princess the
armies were no there is no princess
warrior achar peace Beastmaster you
think of the beast man no these god
these families they should remake the
Beastmaster what I think you're in the
wrong riot oh [ __ ] yeah get I'm at the
network right yeah get out of here
so they said there are no better than
Indians half-breeds who had filthy homes
they
didn't know how to treat white children
one woman she said she said this is
after hours yeah
they don't know how to treat the
children one woman said she saw a New
Mexican mother give a beer to her child
okay another said they poisoned kids
with spicy Mexican food that's well
that's true I mean how many more have to
die at the hands of pico de gallo that's
why they call it pico de gallo be good
to by all the priests was terrible
selling them to the highest bidder they
also said I'm gonna be at ninety nine
now they're doing Ted Ted Ted Ted eleven
eleven eleven twelve twelve thirteen
thirteen to eighteen I'll do I 14 to
here 14 through 15 15 baby 15 go 150 go
truck
this man has a baby yeah I'm gonna eat
it legally okay with us
I got a baby hunger different kind
different kind than you man I'd like to
eat him cuz there's song we can't sell
to the guy cooking in my green egg it's
a smoker so there are eight female
ringleaders and they persuaded five men
to do something about the situation well
good this always ends well the men went
to the sheriff but he told them he
couldn't arrest the Mexicans without a
reason right okay so you know sometimes
Dave we get so mired and the dumb
reality that I forget that there is
potential for someone to actually just
call out reality and just say what has
to be said which is oh no there's no
reason to do that
so no absolutely not but he did agree to
go to mourn see to find the priest an
agent bring them back so he's in
Cliffton so he says I'm gonna go up
tomorrow and see I'm gonna get the
priest in the agent or I'm bringing back
we're gonna figure this out okay I know
I wonder white guys like I'll go with
you so now it's the white guy in a
sheriff heading up there okay good so
first I got there they found sister Anna
who told them she was going to inspect
the homes and take away the kids if it
wasn't good enough so she's like no we
had this handled if it's not look
there's hot sauce we take this we've
been very clear
and I think we know the parameters are
dealing with there's any Pico getting
them jumping around being yeah yeah here
it so the sheriff who's now been joined
by another man from Warren see okay they
they confront an agent Swain in his room
so they saw up to his room it's a bad
look one of the men was the mine boss
who told Swain the Mexicans didn't earn
enough money and he knew that because he
didn't pay them enough interesting
admission I know they don't have the
money because I'm an [ __ ] how do you
think I'm rich yeah rumors swirled in
the mining camp that the white children
quote were going to stay in the
half-breed homes which not necessarily a
rumor the truth that's what is supposed
to happen they're supposed to stay in
the homes of the people who legally
we're adopting them this was playing
legal adoption plan yes this how it was
planned yes right a mob formed outside
the hotel you know what do we what do we
had a fifty percent per episode mob
right on this show effective or
ineffective they formed often yeah I
feel a mob coming on people stood
outside and they shouted that they would
take the children themselves okay good
better better better better it better so
the mine boss then lectured the
foundling group about how awesome racial
discrimination was in the southwest yes
okay keep the placement quote violated
some of the deepest feelings and
strongest convictions in the Americans
in the community good obviously
Americans men white because a lot of
these people are Mexican Americans but
obviously American men white ya know day
you know I'd thankfully I feel like oh
yeah well it we had a brief detour but
we're back on track we're right there
now thankfully so there's about seven
hundred whites who live in Warren C four
hundred of whom are now outside the
hotel Jesus they pushed in and yelled
they would tar and feather the priest in
the agent
one of the nuns quote is this still the
French one yeah I mean he must just be
like sorry they're cool not sure why I
would be tarred and feathered this was a
agreed-upon that's what I thought
what are the nuns quote in the street a
sheriff's out on horseback with a
revolver like the other men women called
us vile names and some of them put
pistols to our heads they said there was
no law in that town and that they made
their own laws
none meet gun so it seems cool
yeah no no this is for sure how you drew
this is still how adoption is that is
done in the alright well we'll just be
outside leering for a week and make sure
the kids not distressed okay and if it
is will come in and yank it in Cliffton
so that's in morons you know and Clifton
a crowd had been growing bigger and more
angry by the hour throughout the day
sure they learned in the afternoon from
a phone call that agent Swain would not
give in very very white woman Muriel
Wright urged the quote good citizens of
the town to rescue these babies rescue
them from the people who are assumed
feeding them and have a bed for them and
stuff well I mean to be fair only one
meal could have been served by her so
you know it's hard to judge so 25 white
men formed a posse so now there's a
posse in the mob this is this is the
other town but still a posse but I
thought we had a mob as well we kind of
do so we do have a posse inside a mob
situation yeah we got a posse in the
moment they said there was no law in
that town and that they made their own
website
switched around so they throw some tea
on the chair it'll destroy a former
posse okay they include two deputy
sheriffs in the posse and a
superintendent at the smelter so a high
up diet that they smell there and then -
so bigwigs right sure yeah I know the
guys high up in smelting tops melts in
the smoke and what are you gonna say put
a name of the show on pitching well
that's good - I see that in Bravo
and link your future up the hill and
morin see facing an unwinnable situation
sister Anna ordered Swain to go get the
already placed kids in Morin C from
their new homes funny funny enough when
when autocorrect when I didn't catch it
it spells Marcia's moronic I just know
the tale okay so now now the plan is
removal and be removed because their
lives are at stake
absolutely absolutely these children who
were living on the streets of New York
and now who have homes will not digest
problem and remember people this is very
anti-catholic time so nuns are not
something that like it's almost like you
know the way people would be upset about
Muslims today it's like that sort of
situation
so cool and then after he got the kids
out of the homes in Warren see he was to
go to Clifton and get the kids there and
how does he do that he sort of got like
a when you catch a bunch of fish just
like a thing with a lot of hooks in it
yeah you have a sort of sheepdog with
you it's like a born but it's got like
25 oh yeah yeah that's great like that
or you just got a bunch of those little
straps like that you yeah a little
elastic so yeah leash
or you're walking around like the dog
whisperer gosh boys mush be mush
no babies just yeah gravel hurts their
hands I think you know what they can
move yeah they can move their little so
as is the way in the area when people
start fighting started raining like
crazy oh my gosh okay
the priest in Swain went out in the
torrent of rain told the new parents to
bring their children to the hotel
immediately storm or no storm okay the
soaked family started showing up at 7:30
p.m. and the last came at 10:00 p.m.
sorry as each family walked in the mine
boss would read aloud how much the
father's wages were what a dick
god damn just the word the worst [ __ ]
yeah like everybody's terrible but then
there's this guy who's like I want to
win it the guy who doesn't pay them
enough is then reading out how little he
pays them not understanding that that
makes him a [ __ ] double-a hey you're
a real dick I know
wait what by the way see who shows up to
work Monday to me your labor is worth
nothing and Clifton the posse set out
after dark in the rain okay armed with
rifles and revolvers nice a delivery man
for the Arizona copper company store
knew where the houses were because he
was the delivery man for the store so
the copper man's gonna be the problem he
called the foster parents his longtime
customers quote half Indians of the
lowest kind cool okay so it looks like
the mine boss isn't necessarily gonna
run away with this one I don't know
about copper delivery man the posse went
house-to-house and demanded each orphan
the posse went house-to-house and
demanded each orphan yeah I mean America
beautiful but when they got to we're
taking your kid back there's a good
amount of us there we go
All Right see you later ma'am that's my
husband only makes a dollar it's raining
out there how you doing ma'am sorry we
were just next door oh there we go here
he is the little one put him on the
loose there we go thank you how do you
know that I'm the dick it doesn't pay
you want anything I've got real issues I
didn't think that I'm actually shouting
this I think the lapses I have what a
nightmare it must be to be a lonely old
mine how much you making here a lot cuz
I rip off all the tedious
so when they got to the home of the
Chaconne I was a bit awkward because she
was the town teacher and he made the
highest wage of all the Mexicans in town
and the delivery man felt a little bit
ashamed knowing they were quote honest
people but you know they took the baby
oh yeah they're half Indians or whatever
is the posse guard agreed that all
Mexicans are bad well you're running on
Posse fuel at this point yeah no you
mean Kim and it is nice to hear a hint
of morality like there's an ember in
there I I understand disappointing a
child or or foster parents sure real
hard to disappoint a posse yeah you
could see the look in their eyes oh but
what they want to do bad yeah it's
Christmas it's Christmas it's Christmas
at the spur of the moment yeah you don't
to ruin that for the posse well I guess
we're gonna get every penny okay come on
guys we try we try by midnight all 16
Clifton orphans were at the hotel some
of them were sick to their stomachs sure
what do I know
trauma no no no no no not a train ride
followed by relief and immediate removal
it was their hot food you do what's best
for the kid absolutely kids come first
after us a gaggle of white women put the
children to bed in blankets on the floor
so the posse hand it to the gaggle yes
okay so the mob had a posse the posi had
attended to the gaggle they could not
calm down the children and what is with
the kids did someone give a Pepsi well
they were with Mexicans ah there it is
there it is guarantee that's what
they're saying that was one of them for
sure was like I really think so the kids
were freaked out and they couldn't calm
down till 2:00 a.m. sure that's good
yeah one child Josephine Corcoran who
was two and a half saying hysterically
until she fell asleep beautiful that's a
beautiful picture I love I love you know
you're doing good when a two and a half
year old hysterically sings her soft oh
my god just a win
and that's that's when it feels good to
be a white person because you know maybe
there's a baby
and she's dancing like she's never
[Music]
danced around midnight with the
intention of sleeping in the hotel and
then getting up in the morning and
getting all the kids from Clifton right
but then they got there and they found
out that the hotel is full of kidnapped
children I know we have a room but even
though they had all the kids the white
people were still furious at the priest
and swain what also what is the plant
what is the white what does their plant
the whites okay they demanded that agent
Swain wire the foundling office in New
York to get permission for the white
families to keep the children okay so I
so I mean look Dave I've bought a candy
bar at checkout before I know what it's
like to not want to make a purchase and
make one on a whim the is it possible to
is that possible to go from waking up
with no intent on being a parent and by
that evening everybody is like we're
gonna be parents to these kids I mean in
America anything's possible
yeah I think it's possible underneath
those stars and anything you want and
you want steel baby steel baby as long
as you're white you're fine oh my god
but agent Swain refused to Mack
two men then barred him from the hotel
so he and the priest had to sleep in a
Mexican boarding house that night that
was in place anyone would let them sleep
okay in the morning the white women
started giving up the children that were
not theirs
so it's just sort of dodgeball pick team
rules
get to captain's and go from there quote
people literally began fighting over
children the children were being dickard
over as if at a bazaar okay
so just more trauma more trauma if
you're one of the kids just like
standing there like what if you're the
you know when you used to play sports
and you're the last one that's what I
mean then what if you're that kid
everyone's like that's what it means so
you're like the kid or you're the kid at
the dance who doesn't get asked to dance
and then someone eventually is like my
mom said I have to dance with you
because you look sad you're like I'll
take it okay I'll be this one's mom yeah
I'm actually quite charming if you get
to know me he's got a walleye yeah I
wanted the perfect one well truth be
told one of my hands is broken as well
oh you're basically Mexican here we go
all right well let's raise this thing
hopefully you can wash dishes and don't
mind if the parents have sex in front of
you not gonna lie
you're in for a startling awakening all
right no hot sauce no sauce of the devil
mm-hmm
mrs. Pascoe claimed Jerome Shanley mere
the right took Kathryn Fitzpatrick mrs.
Jake Abram took singing Josephine hey
thank you I'm excited
Laura Abraham grabbed the youngest
Elizabeth Cain it was her birthday in
three days me too for your second
birthday we got you unreachable
unsolvable drama
welcome to PTSD Lois Gotti you finally
got a white kid taking three year old
William Norton okay play them what a
yeah my heart so warm it's great hey
judge arrived so there's a judge that
was sent for of course right yes someone
to what enforce the dumb things well the
the Mexican family's like oh thank god a
judge is coming
feeling they're going to deny me fine so
he arrives on the evening train
the whites were hoping he would make
their stealing of the children legal
sure sure so this is just sort of a
portable judge just sort of uh
like a judge delivery sir they should
have that today absolutely yeah yeah but
the judge said he couldn't sign adoption
papers without authorization from the
foundling it was the legal guardian
pissing rain
it's everything's wrong she's just come
up at like midnight at the same time he
would not give the children back to the
foundling reps so they remained with the
white people so he's like I cannot give
them back to the Mexicans
I couldn't keep him for now not legally
though yeah yeah so when the whites
heard the judge would not help the good
thing this doesn't happen to Mexican
children today it's all good when the
whites heard the judge would not help
they lost their [ __ ] and they chase
Swain and the priest into the streets
Jesus the two men were forced to hide in
the back room of a saloon until the mob
moved on boy that is a terrifying hide
right there yeah I mean that doesn't
sound like there's a window in the back
room of a saloon and then they then they
booked it back to Morin see but things
they it turns out were not good there
either let's go back to the back room
back to the back room back to that
deputy Gus Hobbs told them this is in
Warren see that the whites of Monte were
playing to grab the kids from the nuns
and give them two white parents the
deputy then ordered everyone in the New
York group the foundling as and the
priest to get out of town the next
morning on the 7:00 a.m. train okay
sister Anna said she and her nuns would
not leave and would confront the white
kidnappers okay
giving up their lives if necessary to
protect the children okay all right so
yes that's all right yes we're rooting
but buts waning the priests were like
rude before that and got the [ __ ] out of
there okay we say we're good bye tough
nuns
it's gonna be a horrible video version
yeah um what I just did
townspeople jeered at them as they left
okay so the Denali leaving but it was
like [ __ ] what you wanted sort of can't
win with you
yeah but [ __ ] who Bret white
children that we kept talk with the
trades not moving the sheriff then told
the nuns they would never take the
children from the town because the
engineers said he wouldn't let the kids
on a train okay
god damn yeah then he said Swain had
promised him to children in return for
keeping the agent safes so the deputy is
like none of the kids within the town
also I had a deal with a guy who got on
the train I get to it gets to or excuse
me dose alright alright I think it could
be a good intermediary here first of all
I want first pick and I get to and I
want these two right here the one that
sings on this guy Hobbs now sister Anna
allowed the sheriff to pick two children
okay what she can do that he's the law
like what the [ __ ] sure sure you get two
for sure
he chose Hannah Kane three and half and
Edward Comiskey four and a half he then
gave Hannah to a Clifton smelter boss
and Edward 28 to Kelly so he took their
kittens so it's going so he took the
kids to like curry favor with the rich
guys in town I want to and these kids
like okay finally closure closure touch
me yeah I'm using you as bribes yeah
yeah look at this one huh
welcome to corruption kids you like that
smell better it's your life now and then
the morn see mine boss showed up know
him he said a Clifton doctor who now
lived in Los Angeles wanted the boss to
pick out a child form this is
unbelievable
I oh my god there's a lot of weird
babies a lot and we really have we've
gone through a lot of versions of this
story of what could happen [ __ ] and
sister Lyanna allowed him to he took a
little girl but still the mob outside is
furious I don't even know if they know
what they want anymore right I have a
good feeling they don't armed men
invaded the nuns hotel rooms we want to
be nuns took us a while to figure out a
new track I love the Lord go on behind
them were local women who called the
nuns slave traders and baby sellers cool
yeah cool sister Ana was able to get out
the back and track down the mine boss
who they just given a kid to really do
not have anyone working the back you
know no no back door just all front all
front that's the energy for you um so
she goes to the guy she just gave a baby
to because she's like well I did you a
favor
how about you do me a favor and since
he'd had a nice customer service with
her and nice and helping me pick one out
give me a pretty sweet baby yeah you did
tell me not to get that one because of
his dead tooth yeah thank you
bullet dodged he ordered the hotel to
throw out the crowds so he goes down and
tells the hotel to get these [ __ ]
kids out of here no crowds I mean
people's and then he promised you did
ploys company guards around to allow the
whole party nuns and kids to leave the
next day
so he's gonna he's gonna set up the
guards outside the hotel and then walk
him to the train station okay
so he goes down to the hotel he holds
the crowd back gets it all done
negotiates with the crowd to allow the
nuns and the remaining children to leave
on the train the next day okay so he's
the mine boss so he's basically it's
basically their boss now telling them
what they have to do right okay right so
the next morning the guards escorted the
group to Morenci station they climbed on
a train at 7:00 a.m. and left they left
by 19 kids though that's those the total
that they did not get to take okay when
they got back to New York the New York
Daily News
ran the story and slammed Morin C and
Clifton as the most quote debased
localities that can be found on the
entire southern tier of the state's the
besieging nuns were beaten off and the
sobbing little ones were distributed
among the vilest haunts of the two towns
ah well that just makes you feel good
about the 19 left behind so at the same
time so nice for New York to get on its
high horse right like well though these
places couldn't handle it that we
shipped a bunch of kids there randomly I
know but they're they're ending like
it's awesome when they literally just do
[ __ ] cattle calls of baby yeah that's
what I mean they're like this one was
actually okay like set up legally right
I mean went horribly blam though right
New York gun for sure they're not
allowed to give notes no New York you're
not allowed to give notes on orphans
yeah so at the same time western pay
peas paper western papers went with the
classics with the baby sing
anti-catholic and anti-mexican slurs the
Arizona bullets and attacked Catholics
for selling quote sweet innocent white
American babies to squalid
half-civilized Mexicans of the lowest
class what if you couldn't say white in
the 1800 but wouldn't that have done to
the society if that was not if you could
not say the word white would that would
not have been able to function so it's a
huge scandal people are taking sides
even president Rosa Roosevelt then got
involved and near on a hunt one in New
York wealthy wealthy Catholics complain
to the president who told the US
attorney in Phoenix to help the nuns
okay
a wealthy Irish businessman who now
lived in Arizona would front all the
money for any legal costs help them but
no criminal charges were filed just a
civil suit okay
the county probate court certified the
white parents as legal guardians in
November and the US attorney appealed
with the Arizona Supreme Court to return
the children okay but then the nuns
themselves turned on the Mexican
Catholics during the January night
five trial they said the homes were
poorly chosen and blamed the French
priest father Mandan and all [ __ ]
well there I think the nuns are now like
yeah we need white people right and they
just need to sort of save face right
probably maybe I don't know I just think
it's racism oh for sure it's right know
if it's saving face at all it's just
like they need to put the blame on
someone else I guess but I think it's
mostly just like there with white people
either way it's racist um that's what
matters the French guy just didn't get
Americans love of racism this French guy
just didn't say I mean I don't know what
he did he does I don't know what's
happening you know a French people are
super relaxed and like are not crazy
Alexis have you understand that but the
US attorney argued Arizona was bound to
comply with New York state custody laws
and returned the children all the whites
from Clifton testified with the most
insane racist [ __ ] possible they
called their Mexican neighbors
prostitutes lowlifes and vermin in court
their only real argument was that they
were now families yeah yeah they've got
time on but we're all closed down I play
ball with them I play ball and I put
them to bed and stuff like there's a lot
going on with all due respect your honor
we have pissed on this child he is armed
we have market him as ours we don't give
him any hot sauce you never would we
wouldn't do that to a baby yeah
so they paraded the kids around the
Phoenix courtroom and the children
became these media darlings journalists
reported everything did every gesture
every cute little saying sometimes they
Hanna's next single yeah what's she
gonna do they sometimes stole the show
in the courtroom and the judges were
totally fine with it no no no I want to
see what this cutie pie is taking this
go ahead darling oh my god where is your
nose it's the card ship well I think we
all know you are guilty of being
adorable okeydoke I think well why don't
we all take a recess and I'll let the
kids do a costume change
and then when we come back we can hear
some of the some of the talents of the
other children oh my god they gave me
such a good clean little dolly so it's
big news obviously newspapers reported
it in a very complicated way some
newspapers are Pro Catholics some were
Pro Protestant they were the cliche of
the East Coast attacking the uncivilized
West sure democratic papers especially
Hearst papers emphasized the violence
against the nuns and the priests and
some call that a lynching headlines some
of the headlines children stolen by mob
sisters of charity persecuted armed men
aroused them at night invaded their
rooms and drove them away okay
dregs of nation now hold infants the
vague times some papers called some
people talked of bigotry but they meant
that an anti-catholic way not racist way
great because politics are twisted so
the Democratic Party had the allegiance
of most Catholics but was also the most
racist party it sounds like fake news so
papers had to walk the line of defending
the nuns while condemning the Mexicans
but I'll tell you what's great about
racism Davis sometimes it doesn't need
to be rooted or founded in anything real
thank you and if you can gleam that cube
properly my boy in the red rag the white
family's lawyers based their defense on
race and they went out of their way to
pretend that it was a good religious
town sure they said some of the white
families were also Catholic and totally
denied any religious division in the
town quote the decent citizens of
Clifton and more'n see Catholics stood
shoulder to shoulder with Protestants
they pushed that narrative it was all
about race and that the babies were
better off with whites so that's their
legal argument right the legal argument
is that they're just better off with
whites well it's nice to see whites come
together over really the hatred of
something the foundling attorney to the
opposite he made it about religion and
not race the nuns were on board with
that head sister Theresa Vincent
insisted that quote the prejudice
animating the mob was religious rather
than race
okay such an incident recalls the stormy
days of long ago before enlightenment
had dispelled the clouds of
anti-catholic hatred it is scarcely a
half-century since a know-nothing mob
marched to the Cathedral of New York
with the purpose of burning it she's
Megan yeah she's going hardcore on the
cabbage [ __ ] there okay now they made
his decision
okay-dokey in the court just as ever
Kent praise we want to see more from the
kids about dance the one thing we don't
need to deliberate is would we like to
hear another we would love to Your Honor
may I ask may I ask the infant who's got
my finger I'd like to see where you take
it go ahead here we go I'm gonna sustain
this one that felt like it was a little
too much about you now little darlin why
don't you go back to you hula hooping
would you like to pull my finger judge
please sit down for the last time I've
told you know my one gag yeah and it's
getting real old and you're sometimes
pulling your own finger which really
eliminates a lot of this okay pull my
finger
let's not go there we're better than
this
just as Edward Kent praise the parents
in the final decision that obviously
went to the white parents not a lot of
suspense omission quote they assisted in
the rescue of these children from the
evil into which they had fallen goddamn
I mean these this was planned this is a
clean legal decision we feel that it is
for the children's best interest that no
change be made in their custody the
judge did not mention the moms but
talked about the Americans who had
staged community meetings mean heroes
volunteering heroes do you mean heroes
sir yeah okay remove the children from
quote degraded half-breed Indians legal
legal opinion legal opinion the judges
ruled for the whites and mob actions
because they said they upheld the best
interests of the children and there with
white parents the children got better
clothes medical care and
because the white people weren't paying
the Mexican I know I mean honestly it's
like you don't need to trace it far like
it's not hard why don't you let him keep
the children and raise their wages
I'm afraid I'm completely lost say it
again you see you pay them more and then
they can then they can afford better
things for their children right sorry
with the white families have more and
we'll be able to provide more right but
but they they they hired the Mexican
families that we're going there in their
smelters yes and they have less right so
yeah if you paid them more than they
could rely pay pay the white people to
why people pay the Mexican people more
and then the Mexican people can raise
children no no no equally yes equally
okay but the met you miss spoke you said
Mexicans yeah instead of white people
the white people deserve more no the
Mexican no I'm saying I'm not I'm saying
labor is labor and all people are equal
and that their time is equally valuable
so the Mexican people you should pay
more and then they'll be able to raise
the children with good education
clothing and everything that they need
that's what the white people have that
and again I'm gonna point out that the
Mexicans are not white so I feel like
you might think that they are but
they're not so they can't have that I
feel like we're not talking on the same
I feel like you're speaking Spanish or
whatever that language they are upon is
a rambling on it bothered to pay
attention any who's will be I should get
back I'm actually gonna go get some
horses later yeah no no I'm not good all
right go F yourself it just seemed like
you were looking for an exit though you
can't just stop talking but you leave
and I look physically need to leave
locales not one for letting things just
die out so the courts did not care that
the nuns wanted Catholic children with
Catholic families for the courts race
trumped religion the foundling appealed
to the US Supreme Court and in April
1906 the case was heard by the Supreme
Court which ruled that because the
adoptive parents were Mexican Indian
they were unfit by quote mode of living
habits and education to have the custody
care and education of
children right the Supreme Court unites
into America well Dave I mean like we
were just established through a fun
little scene brought to life you know
there's no solution to this I mean
unless you drop the nuclear bomb of
paying other races higher wage the
unthinkable the Clifton and moronic
white parents legally adopted the
children some went or probably raised as
such idiots
some went to the original woman who had
started the entire battle so those women
right and who kicked it all off they've
got kids but the case hardened the
racial tensions in the I wonder why I'm
no wonder why that happened father man
didn't never returned yeah no [ __ ]
he became a longtime priest in Brisby
Arizona for Irish miners oh my god he
didn't move far I figured you'd go back
it'd be like just like I run the
boulangerie now I said don't talk about
my trip to America much aside from this
picture sister Ana became the leader of
the sister of charity in 1917 the kids
grew up in Clifton and Warren see with
their white parents and we can assume
they're Mexican neighbors would have to
sit there and watch them as they grew up
yeah their entire lives yeah cool by
1945 none of the orphans lived in
Clifton anymore no one knows what
happened to them I can tell you that the
little baby who sang died from being out
in the rain that night no she got an
itch got an illness right after that she
never recovered
that's good ending oh my god holy God
Almighty well at least at least I mean
the cool thing about America is even
though there's injustice it's that the
that our legal system is there to make
sure everything's okay and I think I
think today that still holds true I
think that you know we can see that if
there's ever a problem our legal system
is here to help us no there's stop gaps
for sure yeah it's that's why we have it
it's - it's just stop bad stuff from
happening do you ever feel like living
in America is like being in an arranged
marriage and then you found their diary
[Laughter]
alright farewell
[Music]